Thank you for listening to the rest is history for weekly bonus episodes ad free listening early access to series and membership of our much loved chat community go to the rest is history.com and join the club that is the rest is history.com. So Tom, we have some unbelievably exciting news for our listeners, don't we? We absolutely do, Dominic. The England cricket team will not be the only group of Englishmen touring Australia this coming summer to triumphant effect because we will be as well. We're coming to Australia in November and December this year, and you can get tickets at the rest is history.com. So listen, we will be undertaking four tests for shows in front of our beloved
感谢收听《其余皆历史》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告畅听、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com，加入这个俱乐部，网址是 therestishistory.com。那么，汤姆，我们有一个难以置信的令人兴奋的消息要告诉听众，对吧？绝对是的，多米尼克。英格兰板球队将不是今年夏天唯一一支巡回澳大利亚并取得辉煌战绩的英格兰人团队，因为我们也会去。我们将在今年十一月和十二月前往澳大利亚，你可以在 therestishistory.com 获取门票。听着，我们将为我们深爱的
Australian audience, our very favorite audience, I think Tom, and we'll be doing shows at the Sydney Opera House in Melbourne, and then we'll be doing two more at the start of December in Adelaide and in Brisbane. And we will be talking about one of Australia's greatest exports and the impact that it has had on the understanding of history across the world and through time. So tickets are on sale now for our beloved members of the Rest is History Club. And if you want to snap those tickets up early, you should join the Rest is History Club at therestishistory.com. And tickets will be available to purchase for everyone else from this Thursday, that's
澳大利亚观众进行四场巡演。我想汤姆，这是我们最喜爱的观众，我们将在悉尼歌剧院和墨尔本举办演出，然后我们将在十二月初在阿德莱德和布里斯班再举办两场。我们将讨论澳大利亚最伟大的出口产品之一，以及它对世界各地和各个时期人们对历史理解的影响。因此，“其余皆历史俱乐部”的挚爱会员现在就可以买票了。如果你想提前抢购这些门票，你应该在 therestishistory.com 加入“其余皆历史俱乐部”。其他所有人都可以从本周四开始购票，也就是
the 3rd of July at 11am Australian Eastern Standard Time. So for your chance to see us live on stage in an Australian city near you, head to the restishistory.com, to the rest is history dot com. Join the club and get your tickets. The Freeman's Journal, 22nd of November, 1920. Where will it end? Yesterday morning, some 14 officers and men of the military and secret services were shot dead at the same hour in widely separated districts of the city, some in hotels, some in private residences.
7月3日上午11点（澳大利亚东部标准时间）。因此，想要有机会在您附近的澳大利亚城市现场观看我们的演出，请前往 therestishistory.com，即 therestishistory.com。加入俱乐部并获取您的门票。《弗里曼日报》（The Freeman's Journal），1920年11月22日。这一切将伊于胡底？昨天早晨，大约14名军方和特勤局的军官及士兵在同一时间、在城市各个相距遥远的地区被枪杀，有在酒店里的，也有在私人住宅里的。
In the afternoon, the authorized answer of the government agents came in the form of an attack upon a football crowd assembled, unsuspecting of evil, to watch a match in Croke Park. Croke Park was turned into Amritsar, with the difference that there were no proclamations, no warnings, no legalities defied by the assembly in Croke Park. The slaughter was a classic example of a government reprisal. The innocent were shot down in blind vengeance. The pretense that the firing was provoked by an attack upon the government forces will deceive no one in Ireland. It is another base official lie. So strong words there from the Freeman's Journal published on the 22nd of November 1920. And the Freeman's Journal had long been Ireland's leading constitutional nationalist newspaper,
下午，政府特工们的官方回击以袭击克罗克公园（Croke Park）聚集的毫无防备、观赏比赛的球迷人群的形式到来。克罗克公园变成了阿姆利则（Amritsar），不同之处在于，克罗克公园的集会没有任何公告、没有警告、也没有对法律的蔑视。这场大屠杀是政府报复的典范。无辜者在盲目的复仇中被枪杀。宣称开枪是由对政府部队的袭击引发的借口，在爱尔兰将欺骗不了任何人。这是又一个卑鄙的官方谎言。这是《弗里曼日报》发表于1920年11月22日措辞强烈的言论。而且《弗里曼日报》长期以来一直是爱尔兰主要的宪政民族主义报纸，
so backing home rule rather than independence. But there you can sense shock, outrage, and the sense of a newspaper perhaps changing its mind. And the reason for that are the events in Dublin of the previous day that the newspaper is describing. And it is a Sunday that has gone down in history as Ireland's first bloody Sunday. So it's probably the single most notorious moment
因此它支持自治而非独立。但从中你可以感受到震惊、愤怒，以及一家报纸可能正在改变看法的迹象。其原因正是报纸所描述的前一天在都柏林发生的事件。这一天是星期天，在历史上被称为爱尔兰的第一个“血腥星期日”。因此这很可能是
in the war for Irish independence that had begun almost two years earlier. And that is largely because of what happened where we are sitting right now at Croke Park and if you can hear the humming of a lawnmower behind us tending the sacred turf that is because we are this great shrine of Irish sport but Dominic before we get on to the terrible events of Bloody Sunday should we just remind ourselves of where we've got to in the story of the war for Irish independence?
爱尔兰独立战争中最臭名昭著的一幕，而这场战争在大约两年前才刚刚开始。这主要由于我们现在所坐的这个地方——克罗克公园——所发生的事情。如果你能听到我们身后修剪这片神圣草坪的割草机嗡嗡声，那是因为我们正身处爱尔兰体育的伟大圣地。但是，多米尼克，在我们谈论血腥星期日的可怕事件之前，我们是否应该先回顾一下我们对爱尔兰独立战争故事的进展了解到了哪里？
Sure. Listeners will remember that last time, in the last episode, we began with Sinn Fein's landslide election victory in December 1918. And then we looked at what happened over the next two years. The creation of a Republican counter-state with its own courts and local officials. The growth of the Irish volunteers, which became the Irish Republican Army, which is determined to fight for an independent republic. A growing guerrilla campaign increasingly bloody against the British authorities. Reprisals by British troops, by the Royal Irish Constabulary and most famously the Black and Tans and the Auxiliaries.
当然。听众们会记得，上次在上一集中，我们从1918年12月新芬党（Sinn Fein）在选举中取得压倒性胜利开始。然后我们探讨了接下来两年里发生的事情：建立了一个拥有自己的法庭和地方官员的共和派反政府国家；爱尔兰志愿军（Irish Volunteers）的发展，该组织后来成为了爱尔兰共和军（IRA），决心为一个独立的共和国而战；以及针对英国当局日益血腥的游击战不断升级；英国军队、皇家爱尔兰警察（Royal Irish Constabulary），以及最为人所知的黑麦克衫部队（Black and Tans）和辅助部队（Auxiliaries）的报复。
So we reached November 1920. And to guide us through the story of what happened next, what happened here at Croke Park on that day, we have somebody who's no stranger to this stadium, historian at University College Dublin, national treasure and self-declared pound shop bono, Paul Rouse. And Paul, you're actually a historian by training of Irish sport and the interaction of Irish sports and politics and nationalism and so on. So this story has a real resonance for you, doesn't it?
因此我们来到了1920年11月。为了指引我们了解接下来发生了什么，了解那天在克罗克公园这里究竟发生了什么，我们请到了一位对这座体育场并不陌生的人——都柏林大学学院（University College Dublin）的历史学家、国家宝藏以及自封的廉价版博诺（Bono），保罗·劳斯（Paul Rouse）。保罗，你实际上是一位受过专业训练的历史学家，专攻爱尔兰体育以及爱尔兰体育与政治、民族主义等的互动。所以这个故事对你来说有着真正的共鸣，对吧？
It's an extraordinary story and an extraordinary day. It begins in the morning with the IRA killing a group of 14 or 15 agents of the British state largely, though not entirely as we will see. In the afternoon there is Croke Park here in the evening there are further murders and the murders aren't just based in Dublin because there are random killings, randy and acts of violence around the country including a policeman who was going home from Mass in a country town in Watford who was shot dead while chatting to a grocer's daughter and for
这是一个非凡的故事，也是非凡的一天。它始于清晨，爱尔兰共和军杀害了英国国家政权的14或15名特工（大体如此，尽管正如我们将看到的，并非全部）。下午是这里的克罗克公园，傍晚时分还有进一步的谋杀案，而且谋杀案不仅仅局限于都柏林，因为全国各地都有随意的杀戮和暴力行为，包括沃特福德（Waterford）一个乡村小镇的一名警察，他在从弥撒回家的路上，正与杂货店老板的女儿聊天时被枪杀，而
their part the British Army shot civilians in Meath and in Mayo while there was a civilian killed and while Dublin was under curfew. So this is death in an Irish sense on a large scale. The numbers on the day barely reached 40 dead which in comparison to other conflicts in other times will not seem enormous. So in that newspaper report, there was a comparison to the massacre at Amritsar in India in the same year where there were hundreds killed. It's not on that scale, is it? It's not at that scale of number, but it's the nature of the events on the day that are truly shocking.
就英国军队而言，他们在米斯（Meath）和梅奥（Mayo）枪杀了平民，同时还有一名平民在都柏林处于宵禁期间被杀。因此，这是爱尔兰意义上大规模的死亡。当天的死亡人数勉强接近40人，与其他时期其他冲突相比，这似乎并不算巨大。所以在当天的报纸报道中，将其与印度同年发生的、数百人死亡的阿姆利则大屠杀进行了对比。它没有达到那个规模，对吧？它在数字上没有达到那个规模，但当天事件的性质确实令人震惊。
They've left the legacy, which I think we should talk about later on as well, the legacy and how it wound through history afterwards, precisely because it was also an intersection of sport and politics. Right. So take us through the day. Let's go through it in some detail and let's start with, you know, dawn breaks Sunday morning, the 21st of November, and the IRA have a long drawn up plan, don't they? An elimination plan.
它们留下了遗产，我想我们稍后也应该讨论这个遗产，以及它如何在之后的历史中回荡，恰恰因为它也是体育和政治的交汇点。没错。那么，请带我们回顾一下这一天。让我们详细了解一下，并从（你知道的）11月21日星期天黎明破晓开始，爱尔兰共和军有一个精心策划的计划，对吧？一个清除计划。
Basically death squads going out into the city. So the short answer to what happened early in the morning of the 21st of November is that at around 9am, about 100 IRA men, led by the Dublin Brigade of the IRA, targeted 19 men at eight locations around Dublin. Now, before I came in earlier to meet you in the Academy, I walked the streets where those men were based. And it's all in a quite a condensed area in the south inner city, with the exception of one set of killings, which took place in the Gresham Hotel, opposite the general post office where we were the last time you were over.
基本上是暗杀小队潜入城市。因此，对11月21日清晨发生的事情的简短回答是：在大约早上9点，大约100名爱尔兰共和军成员在爱尔兰共和军都柏林旅的领导下，将都柏林周边八个地点的19名男子列为目标。现在，自我之前进来在学院与你见面之前，我走过了那些人驻扎的街道。除了在格雷沙姆酒店（Gresham Hotel）发生的一组谋杀案外，所有这些都集中在南内城的一个相当密集的区域内，而格雷沙姆酒店就位于我们你上次来时所在的邮政总局对面。
So 19 men at 8 locations were targeted. 15 of those men were shot dead. 4 others were injured. A group of other men, an unknown number of other men, escaped all injury in what happened. The men who were shot had been identified in intelligence put together by a special unit of the IRA known as the Squad, which Michael Collins had established in 1919. And the idea was that it would combat the activities of the G division of the Dublin Metropolitan Police.
因此，8个地点的19人成为目标。这19人中有15人被枪杀。另外4人受伤。还有一群数量不详的其他人在事件中安然无恙。被枪杀的人是由爱尔兰共和军一个被称为“小队”（the Squad）的特种部队收集的情报中确定的，迈克尔·柯林斯（Michael Collins）于1919年建立了该部队。其构想是打击都柏林大都会警察局（Dublin Metropolitan Police）G分部的活动。
So that was the intelligence unit and the detectives of the Dublin Metropolitan Police. Their men, those G men, their job was to collect evidence against people who were perceived to be the enemies of the state. Now among the squad were some of Collins' squad were some of the Tipperary men who we met right back in the earlier episode who are now in Dublin as full time soldiers of the IRA. So these killings personally ordered or sanctioned by Michael Collins himself? Yes.
这就是情报部门和都柏林大都会警察局的侦探们。这些人，即那些G分部人员，他们的工作是收集那些被视为国家敌人的人的证据。现在，在柯林斯的小队中，有一些蒂珀雷里（Tipperary）人，我们在之前的剧集里遇到过他们，他们现在作为爱尔兰共和军的全职士兵在都柏林。那么这些谋杀是由迈克尔·柯林斯本人亲自下令或批准的吗？是的。
Yeah. Okay. So talk us through how it works. So there's a good example, isn't there? The one of the killers, a guy called Stapleton, arrives at Baggett Street. Is it 92 Lower Baggett Street where a guy called Captain W.F. Newbury, who's been designated as a target. So what happens there?
是的。好的。那么请跟我们讲讲它是如何运作的。有一个很好的例子，对吧？其中一个杀手，一个叫斯泰普顿（Stapleton）的人，抵达了巴格特街（Baggett Street）。是下巴格特街92号吗？一个名叫W.F.纽伯里（W.F. Newbury）的队长被指定为目标。那么那里发生了什么？
Stapleton and a couple of people who were with him, a couple of men who were with him, broke into Captain Newbury's flat. He was in his pajamas in bed with his wife Hetty, who was over visiting from England. And he tried to escape out a window with Hetty trying to protect him and turn the killer. So he was shot seven times and he ended up hanging from the window from which he was trying to escape. Captain Newbury's wife was, according to William Stapleton, left in a terrified and hysterical condition. It took about 15 minutes for him to die. All the while he was hanging from the window while she covered him in a blanket. The brilliant Trinity historian Anne Dolan, who along with people like Jane Leonard, David
斯泰普顿和同行的几个人——随行的几名男子——闯入了纽伯里上尉的公寓。他当时穿着睡衣和从英国来访的妻子海蒂（Hetty）在床上。他试图从窗户逃跑，海蒂则试图保护他并阻挡杀手。于是他身中七枪，最后挂在他试图逃跑的窗户上。据威廉·斯泰普顿（William Stapleton）所述，纽伯里上尉的妻子陷入了惊恐和歇斯底里的状态。他花了大约15分钟才死去。在此期间，他一直挂在窗户上，而妻子则用毯子盖住他。杰出的三一学院历史学家安·多兰（Anne Dolan），与简·伦纳德（Jane Leonard）、大卫·利森（David Leeson）和迈克尔·福利（Michael Foley）等人一起撰写了关于这一天的伟大著作，安·多兰写道，纽伯里太太脑海中挥之不去的是枪击声、枪手的笑声，以及一个男人在她自己的水槽里洗掉她丈夫血迹的记忆。
Leeson and Michael Foley have written great work on this day, Anne Dolan writes that Mrs. Newbury was haunted by the sound of shooting of gunmen laughing by the memory of a man washing her husband's blood off his hands in her own sink. Oh my God. And had Captain Newbury been a secret agent? Yes, it appears so. And so what is the reputation of the British Secret Service at this point?
天哪。纽伯里上尉是秘密特工吗？是的，似乎是的。那么此时英国特勤局的名声如何？
Because you've been talking about how useless all the various departments of the British state and Ireland are. Do they have a formidable reputation among the IRA and if so, is it deserved? One of the singular truths of Irish history is that Irish nationalist and Republican organizations were repeatedly riddled with informers who fed information through various intelligence units and passed them to Dublin Castle. This evidence was not always convincing. Often it was speculative. Sometimes it was information that was clearly made up by people who wish to impress their handlers and get money. We know all this from spy organizations around the world. I think the issue was what happened with the information when it went to Dublin
因为你一直在谈论英国国家和爱尔兰的各个部门是多么无能。他们在爱尔兰共和军中享有可怕的名声吗？如果是的话，这名副其实吗？爱尔兰历史上的独特真相之一，就是爱尔兰民族主义和共和派组织屡屡布满叛徒，他们通过各种情报部门将情报输送并传递给都柏林城堡（Dublin Castle）。这些证据并不总是令人信服。通常它只是推测性的。有时，它显然是由那些希望给上级留下深刻印象并捞取钱财的人胡编乱造的信息。我们从世界各地的间谍组织中都了解这一切。我认为问题在于，当情报到达都柏林城堡后，如何处理这些情报。但是的，这是一场规模巨大的情报战。对英国政府来说，收集到的情报得到妥善利用至关重要。情报收集得好也很重要。而英国情报机构面临的问题是，他们自己被爱尔兰共和军渗透了，后者将情报源源不断地回传给柯林斯。我们来谈谈被枪杀的人。所以，在爱尔兰共和军版本的事件中，这是一帮臭名昭著的匪帮，被称为“开罗帮”（the Cairo Gang），是一群冷酷无情的英国秘密特工，为了爱尔兰革命的生存必须被消灭。首先，被杀的人并不全都是情报军官。其次，引人注目的是，他们并不全都是英国人。
Castle. But yes, this was an intelligence war of huge proportions. And it mattered to the British state that the intelligence collected was used properly. It mattered that it was well collected. And the problem for British intelligence was that they themselves were infiltrated by the IRA who were feeding information on a loop back to Collins. Let's talk a bit about the people who were shot. So in the sort of IRA version of events, these are a notorious gang, the Cairo Gang, I think they're called, of ruthless British secret agents who had to be eliminated for the survival of the Irish Revolution. First of all, not all of the men who are killed are intelligence officers. And secondly, remarkably, not all of them are English.
所以首先，他们并不全都是情报军官。因此有些人是在错误中被杀的？是这样吗？是的。所以我想我们将他们分为不同的类别。在爱尔兰革命的简略说法中，有一些被杀的是情报军官。在爱尔兰民众的心目中，人们记得柯林斯下令枪杀了14名间谍。而事实是，这根本不准确。
So first of all, not all of them are intelligence officers. So some people killed in error. Is that how this? Yes. So I think we'll break them down into different categories. There were intelligence officers who were killed in the shorthand of the Irish revolution. And in the Irish popular mind, it's remembered that Collins had 14 spies shot. And the truth of it is, that's just not correct.
因此，有些人的确是情报军官，例如亨利·英格利什（Henry English），他在都柏林时使用化名马克·曼（Mac Man）。当他们遭到爱尔兰共和军袭击时，他实际上正与约瑟夫·康纳利（Joseph Connolly）同床共枕，后者也是一名来自韦克斯福德（Wexford）的情报特工，曾就读于都柏林大学学院。还有一个叫阿沙姆·埃姆斯（Asham Ames）的人。在他被枪杀的第二天，《纽约时报》实际上刊登了他与纽约社交名媛米利セント·尤因（Millicent Ewing）订婚的消息，而在又一天后，它又刊登了他的讣告。那里确实有间谍，但也有军事法庭官员、参谋军官和普通警察新兵的混合体。
So some were intelligence officers, including, for example, Henry English, who used the alias name of Mac Man while he was in Dublin. He was actually in bed with Joseph Connolly, also an intelligence agent who was from Wexford and had been to UCD when they were attacked by IRA men. There was also a man called Asham Ames. On the day after he was shot, the New York Times actually carried the notice of his engagement to a New York socialite, Millicent Ewing, and a day later again it printed his death notice. There were spies there but there were also a mixture of say court martial officials,
对，我认为杰克·菲茨杰拉德（Jack Fitzgerald）就是一个很好的例子，全名约翰·约瑟夫（John Joseph），但被称为杰克·菲茨杰拉德。他是一名新加入的警察新兵，实际上来自蒂珀雷里一个著名的盖尔运动协会（Gaelic Athletic Association）家庭。他的父亲是当地盖尔运动协会俱乐部的赞助人或主席。他是典型的老派爱尔兰多子家庭中11个孩子中的老五。他的母亲很早就去世了。
of staff officers and of ordinary police recruits. Right. And a great example I think is Jack Fitzgerald, John Joseph but known as Jack Fitzgerald, who was a recent police recruit who came actually from a well-known Gaelic Athletic Association family in Tipperary. His father was either patron or president of the local GAA club. He was the fifth of 11 children in the classic cliched Irish family. His mother had died young.
他被送往布莱克洛克学院（Black Rock College），也就是德 Valera（埃蒙·德瓦莱拉）去过的地方。1915年他16岁时加入了英国军队，就像当时许多爱尔兰同龄人一样。他随第16师参加了战争。1917年，他加入了皇家飞行队。他的飞机坠毁了。他被俘了。他被作为战俘关押。后来他逃跑了。接着他又被重新捕获。他在1919年退伍，并加入殖民地警察部队去为大英帝国服务，或在世界各地的帝国军队中服役。实际上，他原本预定在两周后的12月5日被派往海外，结果他在床上被枪杀。
He had been sent to Black Rock College, again, the place where De Valera went. He joined the British army in 1915,, when he was 16 years of age, as many people in Ireland of his generation did. He was with the 16th Division who fought at Ganshee and was part of the fight that went on there. In 1917, he joined the Royal Flying Corps. His plane crashed. He was captured. He was kept as a POW. He then escaped. He was then recaptured. He was demobilized in 1919 and he was joining the colonial police to go and serve the British Empire or in the forces of empire around the world. He was due to go overseas actually two weeks later on the fifth of December and he was shot in his bed.
你说得对，被枪杀的人并非全部都与英国安全部门有关。一个例子是，有人被杀的其中一栋房子在莫尔汉普顿路（Morehampton Road）117号。其中的一个情报人员——人们以为是情报人员的人——实际上是一名房东。那是他的房子，而他却被枪杀了。另一个是一个非常迷人、名叫帕迪·麦克科马克（Paddy McCormack）的人，他来自梅奥。他曾就读于都柏林北部的精英公学城堡洛克学院（Castle Lock College）。离开学校后，他是一名职业赛马骑师，曾在爱尔兰各地赢得过比赛，后来成为了一名驯马师并获得了兽医资格。
You're right that not all of the people who shot were even connected with the British services. An example is one of the houses where men were killed was on Morehampton Road, 117 Morehampton Road. And one of the intelligence officers there, people who thought was an intelligence officer, was actually a landlord. was there with people who thought was an intelligence officer was actually a landlord. It was his house and he was shot. And another was a kind of a fascinating man called Paddy McCormack who was from Mayo. He'd gone to Castle Lock College, an elite public school on the north side of Dublin. He was a professional jockey after he left school and had won races around Ireland and then became a trainer and a vet qualified as a vet.
他在1917年加入了陆军兽医兵团并赢得过比赛。所以我们曾驻扎在基尔代尔郡（Kildare），驻扎在埃及。战后，他申请并赢得了一份在开罗管理赛马的工作，他正准备去那里上任。保罗，请问，“开罗帮”（the Cairo set）这个词或名字是给这群特工和被枪杀的人的吗？是的，格拉夫顿街（Graft顿街）有一家咖啡馆。秘密特工们在那里会面。但很多人都去那里。
He joined the Army Vet Corps in 1917 won races. So we were based in the Quora, based in Egypt. And after the war, he applied for and won a job to run horse racing in Cairo, which he was about to go across to do. And Paul, can I ask, the Cairo set is a word, a name that is given to this grouping of agents and people who were shot, isn't it? Yes, there was a coffee shop on Grafton Street. Where the Secret Service agents are meeting. But loads of people went there.
这是一类那样的地方。而且有这样一个传言，说这涉及那些在开罗远离本土的殖民地服务中历练过的人。所以这和这个在开罗赛马的家伙一点关系都没有。不，和他一点关系也没有。但他是一名驯马师，爱尔兰伟大的驯马师J.J.帕金森（J.J. Parkinson）曾与他有过合作。所以麦克科马克当时实际上住在格雷沙姆酒店。
It was one of those things. And there was this rumour that it was about people who'd been hardened in the colonial service away in Cairo. So it's nothing to do with this guy, horse racing in Cairo. No, nothing to do with him. But he was a trainer of horses and the great Irish trainer, J.J. Parkinson, he was involved with him. So McCormick was actually staying in the Gresham Hotel.
他是一个令人难以置信的人物。不太清楚他的生活方式是从哪来的，但他通常只在下午晚些时候起床，除非有赛马，他可能会稍微早一点起床。他过着像西奥（Theo）一样的生活。他过着像西奥一样的生活。他微微笑着。他是一个喜欢——我想也许这也是西奥的特点——喜欢奢华娱乐的人。
He was an incredible character. It's not quite clear where he got his lifestyle from, but he used to rise only in the late afternoon, unless there was horse racing, he might get up slightly earlier. He lived like Theo. He lived like Theo. He was smiling weakly. He was a man who was fond, I think of, maybe this was Theo as well, like fond of lavish
那绝对是西奥。他本应在12月2日与妻子和女儿前往开罗。他的女儿四岁，名叫格蕾丝（Grace），而他却在格雷沙姆酒店的一个卧室里中枪，倒在一泊血泊中死去。所以对所有参与体育运动的人来说，这是糟糕的一天。在这种情况下，一个简单的事实戳穿了“被枪杀的15人全是间谍”的说法。但这正是渗入爱尔兰革命神话血液中的神话，不是吗？
entertainment. That's definitely Theo. He was due to head to Cairo with his wife and his daughter on the 2nd of December. His daughter was four, her name was Grace, and he was shot and died in a pool of blood in a bedroom in the Gresham hotel. So a bad day for people involved in sport all round. In this case, a simple fact that it gives a lie to the idea that it was 15 spies who were shot. But that's the myth, isn't it, that passes into the bloodstream of the mythology of the
这就是战争遗产发挥作用的方式。我们稍后会对此进行更多讨论。因此，迈克尔·柯林斯有一段非同寻常的言论，他说他的计划是“消灭那些使普通、正派公民的生活苦不堪言的无赖。如果我还有第二个动机，那也不过是我对一条危险爬虫的那种感觉。通过消灭他们，空气变得更加清新。”他接着说：“在战时侦查或消灭间谍和叛徒是没有罪的。我用他们自己的方式回敬了他们。”我想，我们对来自各种准军事冲突中的这种语言非常熟悉。但我想，这已经写入了民族主义神话中，认为这是一种净化，认为这是（你知道的）“让空气变得更清新”等等。事后人们未能充分认识到，在被杀的人当中包括像麦克科马克这样的平民。科马克家族并没有就此罢休。他们一直在说，这是在对一个被你们杀死的人进行无端的诽谤。他根本不是间谍。是的。
Irish revolution. It's the way the legacy of war works. And we'll talk more about that in a little bit. So Michael Collins has this extraordinary passage where he says his plan was the destruction of the undesirables who made miserable the lives of ordinary, decent citizens. If I had a second motive, it was no more than a feeling such as I would have for a dangerous reptile. By their destruction the very air is made sweeter." And he went on to say, there's no crime in detecting or destroying in wartime the spy and the informer. I've paid them
因此，有趣的是，你提到了安·多兰的文章，她审视了实际执行暗杀的人。这里描述了枪手们的笑声以及在水槽里洗手的家伙，但其中一些人因为实施了暗杀而受到了创伤。是这样吗？哦，受到了极大的创伤。我们之前在谈论这一点：包围每场冲突的神话，在——正如我们之前谈论的那样，人们将为爱尔兰牺牲进行浪漫化。但将杀害另一个人类的行为浪漫化是相当困难的。而安·多兰……
back in their own coin. And that's the language that we're very familiar with from all kinds of kind of paramilitary conflicts and so on, I guess. But that's gone down in, I guess, nationalist mythology, that it's a kind of a cleansing, that it's, you know, making the air sweeter and whatnot. And there was a failure to properly recognize afterwards that among those killed was civilians such as McCormick. The Cormick family didn't leave a go. They kept at it to say that this is heaping columnarly on a man who you've killed. He was no spy. Yeah.
特别是当他们和啜泣的妻子一起挂在窗户上时。这并不是一个吸引人的场景。这绝不是构建神话的材料。我之前提到了安·多兰的文章《血腥星期日的杀戮：1920年11月》（Killing on Bloody Sunday, November 1920）。
So the men who were doing the killing, interestingly, you mentioned Anne Dolan in her article, and she looks at actually the people who carried out the killings. And there's a description of the gunmen laughing and the bloke washing their hands in the sink, but some of them are kind of traumatized by having done the killings. Is that right? Oh, deeply traumatized. We were talking about this earlier, the mythology that wraps itself around every conflict where,
她审视了这些生活的影响，其中一部分就是审视生活受到的影响。那天参与枪击的一些人受到了彻底的创伤。他们最终陷入精神崩溃、习惯性酗酒或全面的健康崩溃。我举个例子，另一位历史学家詹姆斯·诺顿（James Norton），马克·邓肯（Mark Duncan）记录说，詹姆斯·诺顿表示，他个人对枪杀三名英国情报特工负有责任，其中两人被杀，一人在他们（尖叫的妻子和孩子）面前受重伤。血腥星期日之后，诺顿说他的病情逐渐恶化，直到1921年7月彻底精神崩溃。他无法承受自己所做的事。他的一生大部分时间都在格兰奇戈尔曼精神病院（Grange-Gorman Mental Hospital，当时这样称呼）度过，就在我们位于都柏林北部的这里不远。我认为多兰说得精辟。她说：“杀死一个间谍可能是一项命令或职责，但当你看到的所有东西只有一个穿着睡衣、紧紧抓着妻子的男人时，这一切就很难调和了。”有趣的是，我认为诺顿在格兰奇戈尔曼精神病院里，与那些在大战中为英国军队作战的人共用这家医院。哇。
and made real in the balance that we were talking about earlier, where it's about people romanticizing, dying for Ireland. But it's quite difficult to romanticise killing another human being. And, Andolan. Well, particularly if they're hanging out of windows with their wives subbing. It's not an attractive proposition. It is not the stuff which mythologies are constructed around. And I mentioned Andolan earlier in her article, Killing on Bloody Sunday, November 1920.
他们自己也受到了创伤。保罗，这是否意味着，即使在两年之后，实际的杀戮习惯对人们来说仍然是令人不安和创伤性的？在某种程度上，平民生活和和平的正常习惯并没有完全被打破？
And she looked at the impact of the lives, part of the thing was, was to look at the impact of the lives. And some of the men who carried out shootings on that day were utterly traumatized. They ended up in nervous breakdowns, in habitual drunkenness or in general collapse of health in all of this. I'll give you an example, James Norton, another historian, Mark Duncan has recorded that James Norton said that he was personally responsible for the shooting of three British intelligence officers, two of whom
是的。我认为这完全关乎这里战争的性质，一个人可能只会开一把枪，那可能是他第一次开枪，或者是他们许多人第一次开枪。首先，很难弄到枪。其次，它们只在特定的时间用于特定的地方。习惯性的使用是很难实现的。说到正常的习惯，都柏林市的日常生活的节奏在枪击当天依然在继续。因此，例如，体育比赛仍然在进行。
were killed and one seriously injured or wounded in the presence of their what screaming wives and children. After Bloody Sunday, Norton said that there had been a gradual deterioration in his condition until he had complete mental breakdown in July 1921. And he couldn't cope with what he had done. And he spent a lot of his life in Grange-Gorman Mental Hospital, as it was then called, just down the road from us here on in the north side of Dublin. And Dolan, I think put it brilliantly. She said, killing a spy may have been an order or a duty, but there was much to reconcile
是的，这就是问题的所在：血腥星期日早晨的枪击事件只是事情的开始。那天，蒂珀雷里是一个以投掷球（hurling）而不是盖尔式足球（Gaelic football）闻名的县，但他们在1920年拥有一支极佳的盖尔式足球队，都柏林和蒂珀雷里之间安排了一场挑战赛，将在克罗克公园举行。正如你所说，汤姆，这就好像早上的事情从未发生过一样。人们穿过整个城市来到这个地方，就好像这不是一个处于战争中的城市一样。当然，部分原因是对许多人来说，这确实不是一个处于战争中的城市。
when all you saw was a man in his pajamas clinging to his wife. And interestingly, I think as well, Norton, in Grange Gorman, shared that hospital with men who had fought in the British army in the Great War. Wow. They themselves traumatized. And Paul, is the implication of this that even after two years, the actual habit of killing is upsetting and traumatizing for people. And that to that extent, the habits of normality of civilian life of peace haven't completely broken down.
那天这里实际上有两场比赛。第一场是当地的俱乐部比赛。在那场比赛进行的同时，盖尔运动协会（简称GAA，运营这些比赛的组织）的管理人员在球场内开会。他们正在制定未来几个月的政策，而爱尔兰共和军都柏林旅的军官来到体育场，建议取消这场比赛。他们说这很危险。
Yeah. And I think it's all about the nature of the war here where someone might only fire a good, that might've been his first time to fire a gun or many of these. Yeah. Their first time to fire a gun. First of all, it was very hard to get guns. Second of all, they were used only in certain places at certain times. The habitual usage is very difficult to deliver. And talking of the habits of normality, those rhythms of daily life are carrying
他们听说有风声说英国军队会来到克罗克公园搜查人员。盖尔运动协会的官员说比赛将照常进行。如果不举行比赛，就好像我们在某种程度上承认自己与早上的事件有共谋一样。此外，球场内已经聚集了大批已经付过门票钱的观众，这本身就会产生问题。因此，大门在下午2点刚过时就打开了。
on in the city of Dublin, the day of the shooting. And so for instance, you have sports fixtures, they are still going ahead. Yeah. And that's the thing about it is that the killings on the morning of Bloody Sunday were only the start of things. That day, Tipperary is a county more famous for hurling than for Gaelic football, but they had a brilliant Gaelic football team in 1920 and a challenge match was set up between Dublin and Tipperary to be played here in Croke Park. And it was as if, as you say, Tom, the morning had never happened. People were coming across the city to this place as if this was not a city at war. And of course, partly because for a lot of people, it wasn't really a city at war.
场内安保人员到位了。售票员就站在我们来时走过的路上——当我们绕着体育场走、穿过小巷和街道时，到处都是售票员在向进场看球的人卖票。据估计，当比赛在三点一刻开球时，这里大约有5000人。这5000人的门票收入是要归共和军的。那么当时的容量是多少？
There was actually two games here that day. The first was a local club match. And while that was taking place, there was a meeting of GEA administrators in the ground, the Gaelic Athletic Association shortened to GEA, the organisation who runs these games. They were making policy for the coming months and officers of the Dublin Brigade of the IRA came to the stadium and they advised that the match should be called off. That this was dangerous.
它大约可以容纳12,000到15,000人。有时据说可以容纳更多，达到……所以大约是一半。你知道，它绝不是人满为患的。因此，我们有来自一个叫杰克·斯科尔迪斯（Jack Scholdis）的人对当时情况的记述。他曾赢得都柏林全岛足球锦标赛冠军，现在是一名爱尔兰共和军成员，同时也是一名主要的盖尔运动协会官员。他讲述了这样一个故事：比赛开始了，然后一架飞机飞过
They had heard whispers that the British forces would be coming to Croke Park and to look for people. The GAA official said the match will go ahead. If it weren't to go ahead, it would be like us saying that we were somehow complicit in what happened in the morning. And also there was a large crowd inside the ground already who had paid money and that itself can create an issue. So the styles had opened just after 2pm.
球场上空，飞机发出某种信号，或者飞机在进行侦察之类的。那么关于这架飞机是怎么回事？是的，这也是那些错综复杂的网之一，人们会说：“哦，那是为了发出信号，说比赛已经开始了，你们现在可以进去了，你们可以制止事情，你们可以搜查人并让他们离开。”但同样，在所有这一切中，有时很难将神话与历史区分开来。确实有一架飞机，我们知道它在侦察，我们知道，但这种侦察究竟是如何被利用的，并不完全清楚。我们所知道的是，在比赛开始15分钟后，也就是在3点30分，英国军队和当地警察的
The stewards were in place. The ticket sellers were on the roads that we came through on the way here when we walked around the stadium, down the lanes and in the roads were people out selling tickets for people to come into the game. And they reckon that by the time the ball was thrown in to start the match at quarter past three, there were about 5,000 people here. And the proceeds of those 5,000 people here were to go to the Republicans. And what would the capacity have been then?
卡车和团抵达了球场，他们开始从体育场外面向人群开枪。威尔·巴伦（Will Barron），对。他们是来做什么的？是因为他们认为杀手在人群中，还是人群中有走私武器的人，或者是他们的理由是什么？管理层的心里很清楚，盖尔运动协会与民族主义运动结盟，而民族主义运动及其比赛被用作共和派活动的掩护。
It could hold more or less 12 to 15,000. Sometimes it says it could go more than that and go up to. So about half. You know, it wasn't intensely packed by any means. So we have an account of what happened from a guy called Jack Scholdis. He'd won the all-island football championship at Dublin and now as an IRA man, and he's also a leading GAA official. And he tells the story that the match starts and then an aeroplane flies over
这个论点被夸大了，但并非完全没有根据。球场里确实有人参与了当天早些时候发生的事件。哦，对。好吧。但身上并没有枪支和能够识别他们身份的标记。所以就是这样。英国军队怎么会向一场足球比赛开枪，这确实是你最根本的疑问？
the ground and there's some kind of signal that comes from the plane or the plane is spotting or something. So what's the story with the plane? So again, this is one of those tangled webs where people are saying, oh, it was to send a signal to say the game had started and you can go in now and you can halt things and you can search people and make them leave. But again, it's hard sometimes to separate the myth from the history here in all of this. That there was a plane, we know that it was scouting, we know, but precisely how that scouting was used is not entirely clear. What we do know is that 15 minutes after the match started, that is to say at 3.30, the lorries
我们是怎么走到这一步的？嗯，发生的情况是，在早晨暗杀事件发生后的几分钟乃至几小时内，统治英国政府的官员和安全部队中毫无疑问充满了极度的反感、恐惧、愤怒和狂怒。他们失去了朋友，失去了核心特工。当时的愿望似乎是要做出回应，被认为要立即采取行动。这被认为是至关重要的。他们知道比赛正在进行，并且他们确实相信比赛被用来将人员送进和送出都柏林。我已经提到了蒂珀雷里在这一切中的作用，以及后来加入的其他因素。因此，都柏林城堡下达了一道命令，允许对这些场地进行搜捕武装人员的突袭。因此，大致的计划是从三个不同的方向接近克罗克公园。现在，你可以看到这里现在宏伟的体育场可容纳近83,000人。但在那个阶段，你拥有的是一个更小的场地，周围环绕着一排房屋。我们之前走过的那条小巷，
and regiments of the British army and of the local police arrived to the ground and they began firing on people from outside the stadium. Will Barron Right. What have they come for? Is it because they think the killers are in the crowd or that there are people in the crowd who are smuggling weapons or what's their rationale? It was clear in the mind of the administration that the Gaelic-Athletic Association was allied with the nationalist movement and that the nationalist movement and its games were used as a cloak for Republican activities.
它们更符合后面房屋的高度。它融入了城市的建筑环境中，而不是在建造方式上从那种环境中脱颖而出。因此，计划是从三个不同的方向过来。第一批军事人员要顺着罗素街（Russell Street）下来——我们之前开车走过那里，经过现代公会酒吧（Guilds pub），并在琼斯路（Jones's Road）的桥上停下来，基本上就是现在的霍根看台（Hogan stand）和戴文看台（Daven stand）的拐角处。
This was overdone as an argument, but it wasn't entirely baseless in its notion. And there were people in the ground who'd been involved in what happened earlier that day. Oh, right. Okay. But not with guns and markers that would have identified them. So this is it. This is it. The British forces, how could they be firing on a football match is really your basic question.
来到这里的部队是皇家爱尔兰警察和黑麦克衫部队的结合。也就是说，由E.J.米尔斯少校（Major E.J. Mills）指挥的警察及其支援部队黑麦克衫部队，他们将控制这里的运河端入口。第二组是威灵顿公爵团（Duke of Wellington's regiment）的士兵，由罗伯特·布雷中尉（Lieutenant Robert Bray）指挥。他们在场地的另一端占据了一个位置，虽然在道路的同一侧，
How do we get to that point? Well, what had happened was in the kind of the minutes and then the hours after the morning assassinations, there was utter revulsion and fear, no doubt as well, and shock and rage amongst the officials who ran the British state and amongst the security forces. They had lost friends and they'd lost key operatives. And the desire was seen to be to respond, to be seen to act immediately. And that was considered to be paramount. They knew the match was taking place and they did believe that the match was used
在现在现代纳利露台（Nallie Terrace）后面的另一个入口处。第三组士兵来到我们身后的第三个也是最后一个出入口。他们要封锁那个通往圣詹姆斯大道（St. James's Avenue）的大门。因此从理论上讲，克罗克公园的所有大门现在都关闭了，里面每个人离开时都可以被搜身，任何据称应该在那里的枪支都可以被没收，持有枪支的人也可以被抓获。那么你是如何从这一点——
to pass people in and out of Dublin. And I've mentioned already about the role of Tipperary and all of this and the fact that it was then added to stuff. So an order was issued from Dublin Castle, which permitted a raid on these grounds for men in arms. So the loose plan was to approach Croke Park from three different directions. Now, you can see the magnificent stadium that's here now holds almost 83,000 people. But what you had at that stage was a much smaller ground with a row of houses around it. Those laneways that we walked
我能理解那是怎么运作的。他们打算在场外等候人们离开，然后在出口处对他们进行搜查——你是如何如此迅速地发展到他们实际上拔出自己的枪并开火的呢？因此，你得到的不是拦截搜查行动，基本上是一场对无辜男子、妇女（嗯，男子、一个女人和儿童）的屠杀。当我说的那第一组人员——警察和黑麦克衫部队——到达琼斯路上的桥时，他们中的几个人由于早上大环境之外仍无法解释的原因，以及我们之前所说的那样，开始从桥上、从球场外面开火。我们在开篇时提到的《弗里曼日报》的报道称，开火是由对政府部队的袭击引发的。这被直接驳斥为不实之言。
through earlier, they were more in keeping with the height of the houses it, those laneways that we walked through earlier. They were more in keeping with the height of the houses behind that. So it was built into the environment of the city rather than standing out from that environment in how it was done. So the plan was to come from three different directions. The first group of military personnel were to come down Russell Street, where we drove down earlier, past the modern Guilds pub and to stop at the bridge on Jones's road, basically at the corner of what is now the Hogan stand and the Daven stand.
我的意思是，我们知道吗？我们怎么知道这一点？也许确实有。我们稍后会回到这一点，但没有产生哪怕一星半点的证据证明第一枪来自内部。没有什么令人信服的证据。有过各种各样的指控和反指控。但当你看到我们后面谈到的调查时，你会发现指向相反方向的证据。这里露台的背面有一堵高墙，就在开火的桥旁边。子弹正是穿过那堵墙，射入了球场这一侧的树木中。
The force that came here was a combination of RIC men and black and tans. That is to say the police and their support, the black and tans who had come in commanded by Major E.J. Mills and they were to take control of the entrance at the canal end here. The second group were soldiers from the Duke of Wellington's regiment who were commanded by Lieutenant Robert Bray. And they took a position at the opposite end of the ground, though along the same side of the road,
这种情景——男孩和女孩坐在树上观看体育比赛（你知道的）——
at another entrance behind what is now the modern Nallie Terrace. And a third group of soldiers came right behind us here to the third and last exit and entrance into the ground. They were to block that gate which opened out onto St. James's Avenue. So in theory all the gate into Croke Park were now closed off and everyone in the ground could be searched as they left and whatever guns were supposed to be there could then be taken and the men with them. So how do you get from that? Which is, I can understand how that works. They're going to wait outside the ground for people to leave and then search them on the way out.
非常符合某种特定类型的世界。所以有一个11岁的男孩威廉·罗宾逊（William Robinson）正坐在其中一棵树上，他中弹身亡，从树上摔了下来。第二个男孩坐在离杰罗姆·奥利里（Jerome O'Leary）不远的一堵墙的背面。他10岁，当他坐在那堵墙上时，一颗子弹穿过他的头部将他杀死，同样被击落了。不久之后，第三个男孩比利·斯科特（Billy Scott）在球场远端的那条我们走过的小巷里被杀——那条介于克罗克公园和铁路之间的小巷——那里有一个门，子弹反弹将他杀害在那里。因此，来自桥那个拐角处的警察和黑麦克衫部队
How do you get from that so quickly to them actually drawing their own guns and opening fire? So instead of a stop and search operation, what you had basically was the killing of innocent men, women, well men, a woman and children. So as members of that first group I talked about, the police and the black and tans, reached the bridge on Jones's Road, several of them for reasons which remain inexplicable beyond the general environmental stuff of the morning. And what we've said earlier, they began firing from the bridge, from outside the ground. The report in the Freeman's journal, which we opened this with, said that the firing was provoked by an attack upon the government forces. And this is dismissed outright as not being true.
进入球场并继续开火。在那个时候，你可能会想，好吧，这会停止的。他们会意识到自己所做之事的恐怖，但实际上他们继续开火。现在，人群中显而易见是一片混乱，人们在尖叫，四处奔跑，你可以理解地看到发生了一场踩踏事件。
I mean, do we know? How do we know that? Maybe there were. We'll come back to this afterwards, but there is not one shred of evidence has been produced that the first shots came from inside. Nothing compelling. There has been claim and counterclaim. But you'll see when we talk about the inquiries afterwards, the evidence that sits in the opposite direction. There was a high wall running at the back of the terrace here, beside where the bridge where the firing started from. And it's across that wall and into the trees that were on this side of the ground.
我的意思是，我们知道吗？我们怎么知道这一点？也许曾有过。我们稍后再回到这一点，但目前还没有产生哪怕一丝一毫的证据证明第一枪是从内部打响的。没有任何令人信服的证据。只有各种各样的指控和反指控。但正如你在我们稍后谈论调查时所看到的，证据是指向另一个方向的。这里看台的背面有一道高墙，就在开枪的桥边旁边。正是越过这堵墙，进入了球场这边的树林里。
And this notion of. Boys and girls sitting in trees and watching sports, you know, is is. Jumpers for goal posts. Yeah, it's it's part of a very particular type of world. So there was an 11 year old boy, William Robinson, sitting in one of those trees and he was shot and died instantly as he fell from the tree. A second boy was sitting on the back of a wall just down from Jerome O'Leary. He was 10 years of age and he was killed by a bullet that went through his head
这种关于……男孩和女孩坐在树上观看体育比赛的想法，你知道，这是一种……就像用毛衣当球门踢球一样。是的，这是特定世界观的一部分。当时有一个11岁的男孩叫威廉·罗宾逊，正坐在其中一棵树上，他中枪身亡，从树上掉下来时当场气绝。第二个男孩坐在杰罗姆·奥利里（Jerome O'Leary）不远的一堵墙的背面。他10岁，被一颗穿透他头部的子弹杀害
while he was sitting on that wall and again was knocked off. Shortly afterwards a third boy. Billy scott was killed at the far end of the ground here in that lane that we walk through between croak park and the railway there was a gate out on the bullet ricochet and kill him there. So the police and the black and tans from that corner of the bridge. from that corner of the bridge came into the ground and kept firing. And at that point you might think, well, it will stop. They'll realize the horror of what they've done, but actually they continue firing. And now obviously there's bedlam in the crowd and people are screaming and rushing everywhere and you get a bit of a crush on a stampede, understandably.
当时他正坐在那堵墙上，同样被击落。不久之后，第三个男孩比利·斯科特（Billy Scott）在球场的另一端被杀，就在我们穿过克罗克公园和铁路之间的那条小巷里，那里有一个大门，子弹发生跳弹并在那里杀了他。因此，警察和“黑黄军团”从桥的那个角落……从桥的那个角落冲进球场并继续开枪。在那一刻，你可能会想，嗯，这会停止的。他们会意识到自己所作所为的恐怖，但事实上他们仍在继续开枪。现在人群中显然一片混乱，人们在尖叫，四处奔逃，可以理解的是，人群发生了拥挤和踩踏。
And it's a kind of, you know, an absolutely hellish scene. It's a hellish scene and there's chaos, confusion, people running in everywhere. And soldiers at the other end can hear firing coming from one end, they come in and they set up and they start firing and all around the place there's people running for cover, people diving on the ground, people transfixed by the fear of the moment. Paul, one of those men was wearing the coat that is beside you right now, for those who are watching on the video, for those who aren't, it's a coat with a hole that has been sewn back on and that hole is where the bullet went in. Yeah. So this is the coat of Tom Hogan, who was along with James Matthews, a spectator who was
这里就像是一个，你知道的，绝对人间地狱般的场景。这是一个如地狱般的场景，充满了混乱、迷茫，人们四处奔跑。另一端的士兵听到一端传来的枪声，他们冲进来，列好阵势开始开枪。四周到处都是寻找掩护的人、扑倒在地上的人、被当时的恐惧吓得呆若木鸡的人。保罗，这些人里有一个人就穿着你身旁的那件外套，对于看视频的观众来说，对于没看视频的人，那是一件补过洞的外套，那个洞就是子弹穿进去的地方。是的。所以这就是汤姆·霍根（Tom Hogan）的外套，他和詹姆斯·马修斯（James Matthews）一样，是
at the game and they were shot dead as they tried to run. As always happens in these situations as people, or as you can imagine what should happen in these situations, as people run for cover with gunfire coming from different directions, echoing around the pitch, bullets flying here and there. There was a stampede and a crush to get out and people were left lying dead, were dying on the ground and lying injured. And Jack Shouldis, you mentioned him earlier, he said that the greatest crush was on this side of the ground where we are now, the Bali Bach side where hundreds were wounded or injured in the mad scramble that followed or trampled and torn with barbed wire on the walls trying to get
比赛的观众，他们在试图逃跑时被枪杀。正如在这种情况下人们通常会发生的那样，或者你可以想象在这种情况下应该发生的那样，当人们顶着从不同方向传来、在球场四周回荡、子弹四处飞溅的枪声逃向掩护处时。现场发生了践踏和拥挤，人们被抛在地上等死、濒死或受伤。杰克·肖迪斯（Jack Shouldis），你之前提到过他，他说拥挤最严重的地方就在我们现在所在的球场这一侧，巴利巴赫（Bali Bach）一侧，随后的疯狂争抢中数百人受伤，或是试图爬墙逃出去时被铁丝网踩踏划伤。
out with the barbed wire put up to stop people getting in for free. Now stops people getting out for fear of life. And you've people like Jane Boyle shot and crushed in the crowd. James Teehan and James Burke crushed again. Daniel Carroll gets out of the ground, but is shot with a ricocheted bullet. And he died from his wounds in a house outside the ground. And all the while there were still people trapped in here, still trapped, unable to get out.
那里原本架设铁丝网是为了阻止人们逃票进场，现在却成了阻止人们为保命而逃出去的障碍。你可以看到像简·博伊尔（Jane Boyle）这样的人在人群中被枪击和挤压致死。詹姆斯·蒂汉（James Teehan）和詹姆斯·伯克（James Burke）也再次被挤压致死。丹尼尔·卡罗尔（Daniel Carroll）逃出了球场，却被一颗流弹击中。他在球场外的一所房子里因伤身亡。与此同时，还有人被困在这里，依然被困住，无法逃脱。
Jack Shoulders remembered that there were rifles and machine guns trained on people the shooting after the shooting had stopped, but corralling them in and kept there for more than an hour searched as, as they went out of the place. All right. Well, let's take a break now, and then we'll come back and we will talk about some of the people who were killed. We'll talk about the aftermath of the shooting and we'll talk about how this plays out with the rest of the war of independence and how we get from here to the Anglo-Irish Treaty. So come back after the break. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Paul, you've described in harrowing detail some
杰克·肖迪斯回忆说，在枪击停止后，仍有步枪和机枪对准人群，将他们包围并在那里扣留了一个多小时，在他们离开时搜身。好了，我们现在休息一下，然后回来聊聊一些遇难者。我们将讨论枪击事件的余波，以及这如何与独立战争的其余部分交织在一起，以及我们如何从这里走到《英爱条约》。所以休息之后回来欢迎回到《历史余音》。保罗，你以极其揪心的细节描述了
of these scenes at Croke Park. Obviously, eventually the ground empties and we'll come back to the inquiries and the cover up and the way that the authorities try to justify what's happened. A couple of things that you think are important. So one of them is that the events of the afternoon and the events of the morning are inextricably linked. Entirely. So what happened in the afternoon is very clearly a response to what happened in the
克罗克公园的这些场景。显然，最终球场空了，我们将回过头来讨论调查、掩盖真相以及当局试图为所发生的事情辩护的方式。有几件事你认为很重要。其中之一就是，下午发生的事件和早晨发生的事件有着千丝万缕的联系。完全是这样。所以下午发生的事情很明显是对早上发生事情的回应。
morning. It's in the manner of the reprisals, though a very extreme version of the reprisals, which are now becoming common. So the reprisals have almost become institutionalised. The authorities will make reprisals after every, as they see every provocation. Yeah, normally it's localised, it's never on this scale, apart from you could say the burning of Cork was the closest you could get to this. And the second thing is, I mean, it's often described as deliberate and cold
这也是报复行为的一种方式，尽管是现在正变得司空见惯的报复行为的极端的版本。因此，报复几乎已经制度化了。当局会在每一次（他们视之为挑衅的）事件后进行报复。是的，通常是局部范围的，从来没有达到这种规模，除了你可以说火烧科克是距离这最近的一次。第二件事是，我的意思是，这经常被描述为蓄意和冷
blooded. Is it cold blooded or is it in the heat of the moment as it were? In other words, do they know exactly what they're doing, the people who are shooting those guns, or are they out of control and they've lost discipline and they've lost reason? I think they've lost reason. I think they're entirely out of control. I think it's a product though of the perceptions that the soldiers and that the officials held of Irish people and of the nature of the perceptions that the soldiers and that the officials held of Irish people
血的。这是冷血的，还是说就像是在一时冲动之下发生的？换句话说，开枪的人是完全清楚自己在做什么，还是说他们已经失控，失去了理智和纪律？我认为他们失去了理智。我认为他们完全失控了。我认为这是士兵和官员对爱尔兰人以及对正在进行的战争性质的看法产物。
and of the nature of the war that was underway. I don't think it's cold-blooded. I think it's hot-blooded. Right. Okay. You talked about some of the people that died that day, but one person you didn't mention, Michael Hogan. He's a player who dies and he was from...
我不认为这是冷血的。我认为这是一时冲动的。好吧。你谈到了那天死去的一些人，但有一个人你没有提到，迈克尔·霍根（Michael Hogan）。他是一名遇难的球员，他来自……
Tipperary, yeah. Tipperary. Grains Mokler in South Tipperary. He was the Tipperary, Grains Mochler in South Tipperary. He was the only player killed. He was killed crawling off the pitch down in front of Hill 16. He'd been playing on a famous Dublin footballer called Frank Burke, who managed to get off the field. And one of the stands here is named after him.
蒂珀雷里，是的。蒂珀雷里。南蒂珀雷里的格雷恩斯莫克勒（Grains Mokler）。他是蒂珀雷里人，南蒂珀雷里的格雷恩斯莫克勒。他是唯一被杀的球员。他在16号山丘前爬离球场时被杀。他当时在防守一位名叫弗兰克·伯克（Frank Burke）的都柏林著名足球运动员，弗兰克设法离开了球场。这里的一个看台就是以他的名字命名的。
Yeah. The stand across from us is called after Michael Hogan. His brother, Dan, was a leading member of the IRA in the Monaghan area, which is up near the border now. And Michael himself was the IRA company commander in the Grains Mochler area where he worked on the family farm. There is no sense, by the way, that he was targeted to be killed because of who he was. It's just, it's one of those things.
是的。我们对面的看台就是以迈克尔·霍根的名字命名的。他的弟弟丹（Dan）是莫纳汉地区（现靠近边境）IRA（爱尔兰共和军）的主要成员。迈克尔本人则是他工作的家族农场所在的格雷恩斯莫克勒地区的IRA连长。顺便说一句，没有任何迹象表明他因为自己的身份而被刻意针对杀害。这只是……这是那种随机发生的事件之一。
But there was other people. I think in fairness, Hogan's remembered because he was the player that was killed. But like you look at, say, Michael Fury, I think Michael Fury is a brilliant, brilliant example. Michael Fury was 40. He was a labourer who lived in the slums behind us here in Buckingham Street in the north inner city. He actually made it out of Crowe Park having been shot, but he was bleeding so badly that he died out on Russell Street.
但还有其他人。我觉得公平地说，霍根被人们记住是因为他是被杀害的球员。但就像你看迈克尔·菲瑞（Michael Fury）一样，我认为迈克尔·菲瑞就是一个极其绝佳的例子。迈克尔·菲瑞40岁。他是一个劳工，住在我们身后的白金汉街（Buckingham Street）北内城区贫民窟里。他在中枪后其实逃出了克罗克公园，但由于流血过多，最终死在了拉塞尔街（Russell Street）上。
His body lay unclaimed in a morgue for five days. The British Army officer identified him, noted that a number of his teeth were missing and that he was badly malnourished. He also noticed that he was wearing army fatigues and old worn down army boots. And that's because Michael Ferry, like many other people, had fought in the British army in the Great War. And by 1920, in November 1920, he was really struggling, was unemployed. So this is a whole span of people who went, okay, Hogan is famous for being the player who was shot, but Michael Fiery's life is worth as much as Michael Hogan's.
他的尸体在太平间里无人认领了五天。一名英国陆军军官辨认出了他，注意到他缺了好几颗牙，而且严重营养不良。他还注意到他穿着军便服和磨损的老旧军靴。这是因为迈克尔·费瑞（Michael Fury）像许多其他人一样，曾在第一次世界大战中为英国军队效力。到了1920年11月，他真的生活艰难，处于失业状态。所以这里有一群各种各样的人，你会觉得，好吧，霍根因为是被枪杀的球员而闻名，但迈克尔·菲瑞的生命和迈克尔·霍根的生命一样有价值。
Yeah, of course. And the death at Croke Park is not the end of the killings on Bloody Sunday. No, it isn't. Dublin Castle, two veterans of the 1916 Rising and men who were hugely important within the IRA, Padra Clancy and Richard McKee, who'd been arrested the previous night and who were involved in the planning of the Bloody Sunday, the earlier killings in the day were shot along with a man called Connor Clune. So Connor Clune was an Irish language activist and a co-op manager from County Clare who had nothing to do with the revolution. He also had been arrested the night before in a case of mistaken
是的，当然。克罗克公园的惨案并不是血腥星期日杀戮的结束。不，并非如此。都柏林城堡里，1916年起义的两名老兵、在IRA内部极其重要的人物——帕达·克兰西（Padraig Clancy）和理查德·麦基（Richard McKee）——在前一天晚上被捕，他们曾参与策划血腥星期日当天早些时候的暗杀活动，他们与一个名叫康纳·克鲁恩（Connor Clune）的人一起被枪杀。所以康纳·克鲁恩是来自克莱尔郡的一名爱尔兰语活动家和合作社经理，他与革命毫无关系。他也于前一天晚上被捕，这是一起身份认同错误或证据极其糟糕的案件。
identity or really poor evidence. Now it's contested what's happened here in the official version of events. The three men were trying to escape. Now where that breaks down is clued that no reason to escape. Apart from anything else, it said the three of them were trying to escape around 11 o'clock that night and were shot dead. The generally accepted version is that the three of them had been beaten and
现在，关于官方版本的事件经过，这里发生了什么是有争议的。这三个人当时正试图逃跑。这个说法破绽百出的地方在于，克鲁恩根本没有理由逃跑。撇开其他不谈，官方称这三个人是在那天晚上11点左右试图逃跑时被枪杀的。普遍被接受的版本是，这三个人遭到了殴打，
were shot basically summarily executed. For the Dublin IRA, it should be said the loss of McKee and Plancy was really significant. And one of their number said that it knocked all the good out of it. Because it's often said that actually that was more damaging to Michael Collins's intelligence network than the agents who were killed by his agents. Yeah. And it was a bitter blow. And it says a lot for the status of those two men within the IRA that two army barracks in independent Ireland were called after them, Clancy barracks and Marie McKee barracks when, when Ireland, after Ireland, attained
并被枪杀——基本上是遭到了即决处决。对于都柏林IRA来说，应该说麦基和克兰西的损失是非常重大的。他们中的一员甚至说这“把所有的好事都击碎了”。因为人们经常说，实际上这对迈克尔·柯林斯（Michael Collins）的情报网造成的打击，比被他的特工杀害的那些英国特工还要大。是的。这是一个沉重的打击。这也充分说明了这两个人在IRA中的地位，以至于在爱尔兰独立后，爱尔兰有两座陆军兵营以他们的名字命名——克兰西兵营和理查德·麦基兵营，在爱尔兰获得独立之后。
independence. So Paul, the consequences of this, there is a very striking response on the other side of the Irish sea the next morning when the docks at Liverpool are torched. And we should probably just mention at this point that the war isn't confined to Ireland, that there are IRA operatives in England. They are in doing industrial sabotage. There's a plot to poison the horses of the household cavalry
所以，保罗，关于这件事的后果，第二天早上爱尔兰海的另一边有一个非常引人注目的反应，利物浦的码头被烧毁了。我们或许应该在此时顺便提一句，这场战争并不局限于爱尔兰，英格兰境内也有IRA的特工。他们在进行工业破坏。有一个密谋是毒死皇家骑兵卫队的马匹，
to try and stop the state opening of parliament. But there is a very striking attack that happens three months later when IRA volunteers in Manchester are caught trying to burn down Old Trafford, so the football ground of Manchester United. And they do actually burn down a stand at the ground of Manchester city. So maybe there's a targeted sporting reprisal there. I'm not sure. I'm not sure if those are absolutely tied together.
试图阻止议会的国会开幕大典。但在三个月后发生了一次非常引人注目的袭击，当时曼彻斯特的IRA志愿人员被发现在试图烧毁老特拉福德球场——也就是曼联的足球场。而且他们确实烧毁了曼城球场的一个看台。所以也许那里有一场有针对性的体育报复。我不确定。我不知道这些是否绝对联系在一起。
There is blowback in England. And I guess also a huge part of the blowback is that liberal opinion there is massively shocked. I mean, of course, there's absolute outrage in Ireland, but there is also, people are appalled in England too. There is an outcry in England and the claims that were made and it shows you the nature of the outcry that Sir Hammer Greenwood, the Chief Secretary of Ireland, that is to say the most important British official in the country told the House of Commons, stood up in the House of Commons and said that the first shots came from inside the ground, that 30 revolvers had been found in the ground
英格兰确实有反弹。我想，反弹的很大一部分原因也是那里的自由派舆论感到了巨大的震惊。我的意思是，当然，爱尔兰国内群情激愤，但英格兰的人们也同样感到震惊。英格兰爆发了强烈的抗议，所声称的那些言论——这展现了抗议的性质——爱尔兰布政司、也就是该国最重要的英国官员哈默·格林伍德爵士（Sir Hamar Greenwood）在下议院发表了讲话，他站在下议院说，第一枪是从球场内部开出的，随后在球场内发现了30把左轮手枪，
afterwards, that the shots fired in the ground had caused a stampede that it was in the stampede that people had lost their lives. And that these are barefaced lies, are they? Oh, straight up. It's a clear cover up. And more than that, he said that the British forces had opened fire because they were fired on by gunmen who were trying to escape. Again, he said he deeply regretted the loss of life, but this loss of life was
球场内开枪引发了一场踩踏事件，人们正是在踩踏中失去了生命。这些全都是弥天大谎，对吧？哦，绝对是的。这是一场明显的掩盖。不仅如此，他还声称英国军队之所以开火，是因为遭到了一群试图逃跑的持枪歹徒的射击。他再次表示，他对生命的损失深表遗憾，但这些生命的损失
entirely the responsibility of Irish gunmen. And in the way of Irish gunmen. And in the way of these things, there were conservative newspapers in Britain who took this story and ran with it. The Guardian regarded it as nonsense. And the British Labour Party sent over a commission to investigate what happened. And the report of the commission found no evidence that the police have been fired on and condemned instead the calculated brutality and lack of self-control of the police force.
完全是由爱尔兰枪手造成的，是爱尔兰枪手的责任。按照这种惯例，英国的一些保守派报纸接受了这个说法并大肆报道。《卫报》（The Guardian）则认为这纯属无稽之谈。英国工党派遣了一个调查委员会来调查所发生的事情。该委员会的报告发现没有任何证据表明警察曾遭到枪击，反而谴责了警察部队蓄意的残暴行径和缺乏自制力。
And for the next 67 years, further evidence collected by the military and through courts of inquiry were kept from the public. But the historian David Leeson wrote brilliantly on this. He said in November 1999, the public records office in London released three documents. The first was a report submitted by Major Mills on the day after Bloody Sunday. The second was a military court of inquiry at the Matter Hospital and the third was a military court of inquiry at Jervis Street Hospital. I don't think there's any need to rehearse here the full details of these kind of three
在随后的67年里，军事和审讯法庭收集的更多证据一直对公众保密。但历史学家大卫·利森（David Leeson）对此做过非常精彩的论述。他写道，1999年11月，伦敦公共档案馆公布了三份文件。第一份是米尔斯少校（Major Mills）在血腥星期日次日提交的报告；第二份是关于马特医院（Matter Hospital）的军事审讯法庭记录；第三份是关于杰维斯街医院（Jervis Street Hospital）的军事审讯法庭记录。我认为这里没有必要复述这三种资料的全部细节，
sources except to say in the round they demonstrate that the official version of events was a nonsense and Mills wrote that no arms had been found on the ground in search of people. In the round, they demonstrate that the official version of events was a nonsense. And Mills wrote that no arms had been found on the ground in search of people. And the Military Court of Inquiry made clear there was no gun battle. So before, in the last sort of 15 minutes or so of the episode, before we get into the story of the war and how the war winds its way to its conclusion, just to wrap up what happened here at Croke Park, it becomes this absolutely foundational moment in modern Irish history, doesn't it? I mean, it takes on this extraordinary significance
只需说总的来说，它们证明了官方版本的事件纯属无稽之谈。米尔斯写道，在对人们进行搜身时，在球场内没有发现任何武器。总的来说，它们证明了官方版本的事件纯属无稽之谈。米尔斯写道，在对人们进行搜身时，在球场内没有发现任何武器。军事审讯法庭也明确表示，根本没有发生枪战。所以在本集最后的15分钟左右，在我们进入战争的故事以及战争如何走向结局之前，为了总结克罗克公园这里发生的事情，它成为了现代爱尔兰历史上一个绝对具有奠基意义的时刻，不是吗？我的意思是，它对爱尔兰民族主义、
for Irish nationalism, for sport in Ireland, for the GAA. Those of us who follow kind of British and Irish sport will remember the scenes when the England rugby team played here about, was it 20 years ago, 15 years ago, whenever it was for the first time and this sort of day that was freighted with emotion. So what did Bloody Sunday come to mean? Well, not least for the GAA, for the Gay and the Catholic Association. I will come back to that in a second, but I have a real problem with this idea of
爱尔兰体育以及GAA（盖尔运动协会）具有非同寻常的意义。我们这些关注英国和爱尔兰体育的人都会记得，大约20年前、15年前，无论什么时候，当英格兰橄榄球队第一次在这里比赛时的场景，这是一个充满情绪负荷的日子。那么血腥星期日究竟意味着什么？嗯，尤其是对GAA、盖尔和天主教协会而言。我一会儿会回到这一点上来，但我对这种历史呈现方式有一个真正的问题。对我和我而言，血腥星期日的真正意义并不在于宏大的历史叙事，而在于那些失去亲之人的个人痛苦和创伤。杰罗姆·奥利里（Jerome O'Leary）是如何面对他年轻儿子（也叫杰罗姆）的死呢？他不得不去马特医院辨认儿子的尸体。他只是简单地说他是一个学童。布里奇特·罗宾逊（Bridget Robinson）又是如何面对……
how it is presented within history. And for me, the real meaning of Bloody Sunday lies. It doesn't lie in grand historical narratives, but it lies in the personal pain and the trauma of those who were bereaved. How did Jerome O'Leary cope with the death of his young son, who is also called Jerome? He had to go to the Mater Hospital and identify his son. And he simply said he was a schoolboy. How did Bridgett Robinson cope with having to go on a Sunday evening the matter hospital and identify his son. And he simply said he was a schoolboy.
（注：音频此处略有重复）
How did Bridget Robinson cope with having to go on a Sunday evening from her house on Little Britain Street across to the old Drumconjura hotel where her young son William 11 lay a bullet had ripped his chest to pieces. He fought to survive and lasted for hour after hour before he died. Bridget Robinson was 29 when she did that. How did her husband cope? Her husband's name was Patrick. He had been in that hospital as a surgeon sought to save his son's life. How did James Boyle cope with the loss of his sister Jane who was 26 and Annie Burke.
布里奇特·罗宾逊（Bridget Robinson）是如何面对这样一个事实的：在一个周日的晚上，她不得不离开自己位于小不列颠街（Little Britain Street）的家，穿过街道来到旧德拉姆康德拉酒店（Drumcondra Hotel），她11岁的幼子威廉（William）就躺在那里，一颗子弹撕裂了他的胸膛。他极力求生，坚持了一个又一个小时，直到死去。布里奇特·罗宾逊当时只有29岁。她的丈夫又是如何应对的呢？她丈夫名叫帕特里克（Patrick）。当外科医生试图挽救他儿子的生命时，他一直待在那家医院里。詹姆斯·布伊尔（James Boyle）又是如何面对他26岁的妹妹简（Jane）以及安妮·伯克（Annie Burke）的离去的？
Annie Burke came in from Windy Arbor to testify about the loss of her husband. And she just said, he left on a Sunday morning to see a football match. It was two o'clock and that's it. So they're united with the family of Paddy McCormick and all of those other people who were dead whose body laid in blood across this city in two different parts of the day. And again, later that evening in Dublin Castle. And that's the real like people talk about blood sacrifice.
安妮·伯克从温迪阿伯（Windy Arbor）赶来，作证讲述她丈夫的离世。她只是说，他是在一个周日上午出门去看一场足球比赛的。那是两点钟，就这样。所以他们与帕迪·麦科马克（Paddy McCormick）的家族以及所有那些死去的其他人团结在一起，他们的尸体在一天中的两个不同时间横陈在这座城市的血泊中。同样，后来在当晚的都柏林城堡也是如此。这就是真正的——人们谈论血祭。
But that's the real legacy in the blood of the families that were shed and could never, never be recovered. And Paul, that line he left on Sunday morning to see the football match. It was two o'clock. The horror of it is massively amplified by the fact that it is a leisure activity, that it should properly be a kind of safe space away from the horrors of the war. And that's why the story has such resonance and it transforms an understanding as well of the sheer brutality of this conflict.
但这就是真正的遗产，流淌在那些永远无法、也绝无可能复原的家庭的鲜血之中。保罗，那句“他是在周日上午出门去看足球比赛的，那是两点钟”——这种恐怖感被极大地放大了，因为这是一项休闲活动，它本该是一个远离战争恐怖的安全避风港。这就是为什么这个故事能引起如此强烈的共鸣，它也重塑了人们对这场冲突纯粹残暴性的理解。
And what it does, I think, in general, is that it shows you the descent into brutality that was well underway by November 1920. So within a week, you have the Kilmichael ambush near McCroom where Tom Barry and his West Cork. We mentioned him, didn't we? Yeah, so Tom Barry and the former British. Yeah, he'd fought in Mesopotamia. I gather, kind of partly being radicalised by how useless he thought the British High Command were there.
我认为，总的来说，它所展现的是，到1920年11月时已经全面展开的向残暴的堕落。因此在不到一周内，你就看到了麦克罗姆（Macroom）附近的基尔迈克尔伏击战（Kilmichael Ambush），汤姆·巴里（Tom Barry）和他来自西科克的部下……我们提到了他，对吧？是的，所以汤姆·巴里和前英国……是的，他曾在美索不达米亚（Mesopotamia）作战。我了解到，他部分激进化的原因是他认为那里的英国最高指挥官是多么无能。
He was involved in the Kilmichael ambush in which 17 auxiliaries... Which is the worst military defeat the British suffer in the war, I think. Yes, and then a month later there's another auxiliary killed at Dillon's Cross in Cork. In response to that, signed off on, British forces go in and they burned down the city hall and they burned down the Carnegie library. So they're the kind of the high point reprisals. They're the ones that really stand out. But all across the country were small scale reprisals like attacks on private property on livestock on creamers. Creamers matter so much across rural Ireland foundation of the economy there.
他参与了基尔迈克尔伏击战，其中17名辅助警察……这也是英国人在战争中遭受的最惨重的军事失败，我想是的。是的，一个月后，科克的狄龙十字路口（Dillon's Cross）又有一名辅助人员被杀。作为回应，在批准下，英国军队进入并烧毁了市政厅和卡耐基图书馆。所以这些是最高级别的报复行动。这些是真正引人注目的。但在全国各地，都有小规模的报复行动，比如对私有财产、牲畜和乳品厂的袭击。乳品厂对整个爱尔兰农村地区至关重要，是当地经济的基石。
And you can see Crown forces who were bored or untrained or unable to cope with this guerrilla warfare and they felt they were losing. But what's happening is that the war is becoming nastier I guess. A lot of people are dying, there's a sense of possibly brutalization on both sides. Like Bloody Sunday all of this is a terrible propaganda disaster for the British. So abroad you know people look at the burning of Cork or the stories of the reprisals or the story of the shootings at Croke Park and they say, oh, the British are completely out of control. They're behaving incredibly badly and all of this kind of thing.
你可以看到，皇室军队感到厌烦、未经训练，或者无法应对这种游击战，他们觉得自己在输。但正在发生的是，战争变得越来越残酷了。许多人死去，双方都产生了一种可能正在走向野蛮化的感觉。就像血腥星期日一样，这一切对英国人来说都是一场可怕的宣传灾难。所以在海外，你知道人们看到科克的焚烧、报复的故事或克罗克公园枪击案的故事，然后他们会说，哦，英国人完全失控了。他们的行为简直糟透了，诸如此类的事情。
So Britain has lost the battle for worldwide public opinion at this stage. And yet paradoxically, is there an argument that on the ground, the British have actually stabilized the situation to some degree in that they are now fighting back much harder against the IRA. And it's the IRA that are on the ropes in 1920, what are we 1920 going into 1921? Into 21. So the war was changing and the IRA was having trouble getting money and getting arms in. So it's reckoned that there were about 5,000 people in the IRA by May 1921 that they had maybe 3000 rifles, maybe almost 5,000 revolvers, but ammunition was
所以英国在这个阶段已经输掉了全球公众舆论战。然而，自相矛盾的是，有没有这样一种观点：在实地，英国人实际上在某种程度上稳定了局势，因为他们现在对IRA进行了更猛烈的反击？而且在1920年，我们正从1920年走向1921年，是IRA处在风口浪尖上吗？进入21年。所以战争正在改变，IRA在获取资金和武器方面遇到了麻烦。据估计，到1921年5月，IRA大约有5000人，他们可能拥有3000支步枪、将近5000支左轮手枪，但弹药
really hard to come by. That being said, their targeted attacks were causing a lot of debt. I mean, we're going to talk about a truce that comes in the middle of July, but in the 10 days before that truce, 17 policemen were killed. So there were still capacity on the IRA side. But against that, the government is really going after hard reprisals in response to specific incidents. They don't really have a policy though. They don't know how they're going to get this to end. They can't win this militarily unless they go in and raise the place.
真的很难弄到。话虽如此，他们的定向袭击还是造成了很大的人员伤亡。我的意思是，我们要讨论7月中旬开始生效的停火协议，但在停火前的10天里，有17名警察被杀。所以IRA方面仍然具备实力。但与此相对的是，政府正在针对具体事件进行严厉的报复。不过他们并没有真正的政策。他们不知道该如何结束这一切。除非他们冲进去把那个地方夷为平地，否则他们无法在军事上取胜。
And we've mentioned this already. They couldn't do that. It's a public opinion. But I also think it's a matter of capacity because it would have cost a lot of money and they would have had to send in a lot of troops for a very long time. Isn't it the case that the IRA high command is starting to think that they are losing as well? That both sides think they're losing. I think it's a stalemate. they are losing as well.
我们之前已经提到过这一点。他们做不到这一点。这是出于公众舆论的考量。但我也认为这是一个能力问题，因为这需要花很多钱，而且他们必须派遣大量军队驻扎很长时间。难道不是吗，IRA的高层也开始觉得自己要输了吗？双方都觉得自己要输。我认为这是一个僵局。他们也觉得自己要输。
The both sides think they're losing. I think it's a stalemate, Tom. I think it's got into this grim, gruesome dance of death where, you know, they're locked in an embrace from which neither can escape, but neither can really control what's happening. And so a good example of that is
双方都觉得自己要输。汤姆，我认为这是一个僵局。我认为这已经陷入了一种阴森恐怖的死亡之舞，你知道，他们陷入了一种谁也无法挣脱、但谁也无法真正控制事态发展的拥抱中。所以一个很好的例子就是
the Customs House attack, right? So the Customs House here in Dublin, that's May 1921, and it looks like a great propaganda victory for the IRA. They attack this sort of symbol of British power, but they lose an awful lot of men doing it. And they have like a hundred of them captured, something like that. Oh, yeah. It's a disaster for the IRA who go in to do what they said they would never do, which is another set piece engagement.
海关大楼袭击案，对吧？也就是都柏林的海关大楼，那是1921年5月，这看起来像是IRA的一次重大宣传胜利。他们袭击了这个英国权力的象征，但在行动中他们损失了大量人员。他们有大约一百人被俘，诸如此类。哦，是的。对IRA来说这是一场灾难，他们违背了自己绝不进行的原则，进行了又一次阵地战。
Everything was to be guerrilla warfare. So they go in, they burn the customs house and they lose men and guns, which they cannot afford to do. That in itself is a bad, bad blow to the prestige of the IRA in all of that. And it's hard to say that they were about to be destroyed or they were about to lose or that they felt they were going to lose. There was no sense that this was going to end in a military victory for either side. It just did not seem that the capacity was there for either side. Certainly wasn't there for the IRA to militarily defeat the British. What they had done though was destroy the legitimacy of the
一切本该都是游击战。所以他们冲进去，烧毁了海关大楼，并损失了他们承受不起的人员和武器。这本身就对IRA的威望是一个极其沉重的打击。很难说他们当时正要被消灭、正要失败，或者他们觉得自己要输了。当时没有任何迹象表明这场战争会以任何一方的军事胜利而告终。看起来任何一方都没有这个能力。IRA显然不具备在军事上击败英国人的能力。不过，他们所做的是摧毁了英国国家在全国广大地区的合法性，并留下了一个依赖报复和暴力的国家。
British state around huge swades of the country and had left a state that was dependent on reprisal and violence. And is that the feeling increasingly throughout the early months of 1921 in London as well, that the legitimacy of British rule is crumbling and that therefore a new policy is needed, maybe one that's not based on reprisal and force. Well, you can see the first tentative attempts to broker a solution actually began at the end of 1920 when there was a rejuvenator, a kind of a reframing of the British administration in Dublin. And Lloyd George put over people like Andy Cope and Sir John Anderson and came over and they tried to kind of reformulate policy within the organization and there were kind of tentative connections through a Republican businessman called Patrick Mylott as a go-between both sides.
在1921年初的几个月里，伦敦是否也越来越有这种感觉：英国统治的合法性正在崩溃，因此需要一项新的政策，也许是一项不基于报复和武力的政策？嗯，你可以看到，促成解决方案的最初试探性尝试实际上始于1920年底，当时都柏林的英国行政机构进行了一次焕然一新、某种程度上的重新架构。劳合·乔治（Lloyd George）派出了安迪·科普（Andy Cope）和约翰·安德森爵士（Sir John Anderson）等人过来，他们试图在组织内部重新制定政策，并通过一个名叫帕特里克·迈洛特（Patrick Mylott）的共和党商人作为双方的中间人，建立了一些试探性的联系。
It foundered not least because of Bloody Sunday that those initial attempts and then the Archbishop of Perth, a man called Patrick Clune, who was actually the uncle of Connor Clune who had been shot in Dublin Castle earlier. He tried to broker a deal and that didn't work at all. And then there were various writers such as Lady Greenwood and others who tried to get involved. But circumstances, there is a circumstance which permitted for truce. And that was the actual enactment of the Government of Ireland Act that had come in in 1920. In June of 1921, that's open and King George V goes over and makes a speech. So he goes to Belfast, doesn't he, to open the new Northern Ireland Parliament. As you said last time, the supreme irony that the Ulster Unionists, who had been the most
这些努力之所以搁浅，很大程度上是因为血腥星期日的爆发破坏了最初的尝试，随后珀斯大主教帕特里克·克鲁恩（Patrick Clune）——他实际上是之前在都柏林城堡被枪杀的康纳·克鲁恩的叔叔——试图从中斡旋达成协议，但根本没有成功。接着，格林伍德夫人（Lady Greenwood）等各种作家也试图参与进来。然而，局势出现了一个允许停火的契机，那就是1920年通过的《爱尔兰政府法案》的正式实施。1921年6月，该法案生效，英王乔治五世亲自前往并发表了演讲。所以他去了贝尔法斯特，对吧，去为新的北爱尔兰议会揭幕。正如你上次所说，最大的讽刺在于，阿尔斯特统一派（Ulster Unionists）曾是地方自治最激烈、最不妥协的反对者，现在却拥有了他们自己的地方自治议会。他为其揭幕并发表了演讲，这篇演讲是由南非领导人扬·斯穆斯（Jan Smuts）为他撰写、并经大卫·劳合·乔治批准的。乔治五世呼吁结束爱尔兰的冲突，他说，我希望所有爱尔兰人都能停下来，伸出克制与调解之手，原谅并忘记过去，共同为他们热爱的这片土地创造一个
bitter implacable opponents of Home Rule now have their own Home Rule Parliament. And he opens it and he gives this speech written for him by South African leader Jan Smuts and approved by David Lloyd George. And George V calls for an end to strife in Ireland and he says, I'd like all Irishmen to pause, stretch out the hand of forbearance and conciliation, forgive and forget, and join in making for the land which they love a new conciliation, forgive and forget, and join in making for the land which they love a new era of peace, contentment and goodwill. And this is perceived as
新的和平、满足和善意的时代。这被视为来自国王的橄榄枝，所有人都在想，国王竟然会说，好吧，你知道的，事情已经走得太远了。现在是放下武器的时候了。而且我了解到，国王对黑黑卫队（Black and Tans）感到非常震惊。是的。这对劳合·乔治非常有用，这为他提供了一定程度的掩护，因为内阁中仍然有人认为：“我们绝不谈判。这些是暴徒。这是一群乌合之众。这不是一个国家。”
an olive branch from of all people, the King sort of saying, okay, you know, it's gone too far. Now is the time to put down the guns. And the King had been, I mean, he'd been appalled by the black and tans, I gather. Yes. And really useful to Lloyd George, and it gave him a certain amount of cover because there were people still within the cabinet who were like, we're not negotiating. These are gunmen. These are rabble. This isn't a nation.
“这些人没有资格与我们坐在同一张桌子上。”但舆论正在向外扩散。伦敦内部也有要求解决此事的呼声，认为这种僵局没完没了。我只想问一下乔治五世在贝尔法斯特发表的那篇演讲？他是否觉得有必要发表这篇演讲，以便在与共和党人展开谈判之前，确立未来将成为联合王国在北爱尔兰的前哨的合法性？
These are people who have no right to sit at the same table as us, but the feelings are going out. And there's press coming from within London to resolve this, that this is interminable. But can I just ask about the speech that George V gives in Belfast? Is there a sense that he needs to give that speech to establish the legitimacy of what will become, I suppose, the outpost of the United Kingdom in Northern Ireland, before entering into negotiations with the Republicans.
完全正确。这才是整件事情的关键所在。你现在可以开始讨论如何处理爱尔兰的问题了，因为你已经解决了阿尔斯特统一派的问题。这是一个他们想要保留的桥头堡。这使得英国政府在任何谈判中都可以说，好吧，我们讨论的任何事情都可以涉及整个爱尔兰，但这个实际的议会已经建立并在运作之中了，
That's exactly right. That's the key thing in that whole thing. You can now talk about a discussion about what to do with Ireland, because you've fixed up the Ulster Universe problem. It's a bridgehead that they want to keep. It allows, in any negotiation negotiation a British government to say, well, anything we're discussing, we'll discuss all of Ireland, but this actual parliament is in place already and operational
为了这六个现在被称为、或在未来将被称作北爱尔兰的郡。他们这样做是因为他们想把这作为谈判的一部分保留下来，还是他们已经在想：“你知道，如果战争继续下去，我们可以把它作为一个基地来继续进行战争？”我不认为这与发动战争有关。我确实认为这与即将到来的谈判有关。罗纳德·范宁（Ronald Fanning）写过一本名为《致命之路》（Fatal Path）的精彩书籍，里面非常出色地讲述了英国政治内部究竟发生了什么。
for these six counties, which are now going to be called, or will in the future be called Northern Ireland. And are they doing that because they want to keep that as part of their negotiations or are they already thinking, you know, we could keep this as a base from which to prosecute the war if it goes on? I don't think it's about the prosecution of war. I do think it's about the negotiations that are coming. There's a brilliant book by Ronald Fanning called Fatal Path, which it's a brilliantly told story, exactly what happened here within British politics.
停火协议和后来的条约是如何制定的，甚至追溯到1910年，讲述得非常精彩。这是一本写得极其出色的书。让我们快进到1921年7月，几周后。埃蒙·德瓦莱拉（Eamon de Valera）从美国回来了。所以我们现在迎来了德瓦莱拉和劳合·乔治之间的首次会晤，他们的目标是：我们能否达成停火协议？我们能否找到某种论坛来达成协议？因此，双方商定于1921年7月11日实行停火。根据该停火协议，其核心思想基本上是双方在此期间都不诉诸暴力。
How the truce and then the treaty are constructed, but extending back to 1910 takes it all true brilliantly. Just an incredibly well written book. Let's get to July 1921 a few weeks later. Eamonn de Valera has returned from the United States. So we now have the first meetings between de Valera and Lloyd George, and they are aimed at, you know, can we get a truce and can we get some kind of forum where we'll strike a deal? So there's a truce agreed for the 11th of July, 1921. And in respect of that truce, there was basically the idea that there will be no violence on either side on that.
在此之后，英国首相大卫·劳合·乔治与爱尔兰共和国总统埃蒙·德瓦莱拉进行了四次会晤，并互致了大约50封信件。其目的是为开展可能通往条约的谈判寻找基础。听起来有点模糊。是的。最终在11月30日，我知道你将在下一集中讨论该条约，
And in the wake of that, David Lloyd George, the British Prime Minister, Eamon de Valera, as president of the Irish Republic, there are four meetings and about 50 letters shared between them. And the idea is that they will find a basis for the establishment of negotiations, which might lead to a treaty. Kind of vague. Yes. And, and eventually on the 30th of November, and I know you're going to talk about the treaty in the next episode,
但双方达成的一致是，一个爱尔兰谈判代表团将前往伦敦，并将与国王陛下的政府进行谈判，我引用原文：“旨在确定爱尔兰与被称为大英帝国的国家联合体的ASSOCIATION（关联），如何才能与爱尔兰的民族热忱实现最佳调和。”这就是德瓦莱拉对数学的精通在其中发挥深刻作用的地方。但你必须考虑到这一点：这样一场谈判竟然即将与这样一个群体展开，实在是极其不同寻常——他们在1914年《地方自治法案》颁布（尽管尚未生效）时，在许多方面曾是一个边缘得不能再边缘的爱尔兰传统代表。
but what was agreed was that a team of Irish negotiators would go to London and that there would be negotiations with His Majesty's government, And I quote, will have viewed to ascertaining how the association of Ireland with the community of nations known as the British Empire may be best reconciled with Irish national aspiration. This is where De Valera's command of maths is deeply involved in it. But you have to think about this. It is absolutely extraordinary that such a negotiation should be about to take place with a group who now represent a part of the Irish tradition which was utterly marginal in very many respects in 1914 when the Home Rule Bill had been enacted although not had not become operational.
所以我可以问一个非常简单的问题吗？对于我们如何从1914年的那个起点走到现在1921年的这一步，最简单的解释是什么？你认为第一次世界大战是关键因素吗？是的，我这么认为。我认为如果没有战争的背景，由于国内本就有枪支的存在，武装叛乱的可能性就被彻底改变了。不过，真正让激进化进程成为可能、得到推动并在很大程度上向前推进的，是通过阿尔斯特志愿军（UVF）及其走私武器活动所实现的军事化。我认为这从根本上改变了局势，因为它创造了成立爱尔兰
So can I ask a very simplistic question? What's the simplest explanation for how we got from there in 1914 to where we are now in 1921? Is the key factor the First World War, do you think? I do. I think without the context of war, which truly changed the possibilities for armed rebellion based on the fact that there were guns in the country. Really though I think the radicalization process was made entirely possible, facilitated and kicked on in large measure by the militarization through the UVF and their gun running activities. I think that was transformative of the situation because it gave the context in which the Irish
志愿军的背景，而这支志愿军随后在战争的背景下发生分裂，进而通过举行起义的机会积聚了动能，为整整一代人挽回了发动爱尔兰叛乱和拒绝接受国家的理念。从那一刻起，事情真的改变了。保罗，我可以问一个问题吗？我知道这肯定是个无法回答的问题，但假设第一次世界大战没有爆发，假设地方自治得以实施，你认为还会爆发爱尔兰革命吗？爱尔兰彻底离开联合王国的动力会继续存在吗？还是说……
volunteers could be formed, which could then split in the context of war, which can then gather momentum through the opportunity to hold a rising, to redeem for a generation the idea that there would be an Irish rebellion and rejection of the state. And from that moment on, things truly changed. And Paul, can I ask, I'm sure it's an unanswerable question, but suppose the first world war hadn't happened. Suppose home rule is introduced. Do you think they would still have been an Irish revolution? Would the impetus for Ireland to leave the United Kingdom full stop have continued or?
或者我们今天谈论的还会是像苏格兰那样的情况？是的。这是一个很好的问题。正如你所说，这显然是一个无法回答的问题。在阿尔文·杰克逊（Alvin Jackson）主编的一本名为《虚拟历史》（Virtual History）的书里，有一篇精彩的文章专门探讨了这个问题。我真的强烈敦促大家去读读那篇文章。
Or would we still be talking about? Answer Scotland? Yes. I think that's a great question. It's obviously, as you said yourself, an unanswerable question on it. There is a brilliant article in a book called Virtual History by Alvin Jackson, which deals with that particular question. And I really, I would urge people to read that article.
我要说的是，有一群人对仅仅满足于地方自治的理念是无法调和的。他们不会在地方自治法案颁布后就此罢休。现在，那个地方自治议会本身是否会成为实现更大自由的工具，或者它会变成……用柯林斯的话来说，即“赢得自由的自由”？是的，会是那样，还是说它会成为实现自由的绊脚石？这是未可知的。对吧，它会变成苏格兰议会还是加泰罗尼亚议会？
What I will say is that there were a group of people who were unreconciled to the idea of Home Rule being enough. They were not going to stop at Home Rule being enacted. Now, whether that Home Rule Parliament would have become in itself the means to achieve a greater freedom or it would have been... So the freedom to win freedom as Collins will put it. Yes, would it be that or would it be the block on the achievement of freedom is the great unknowable? Yeah, would it be the Scottish Parliament or the Catalan Parliament?
完全正确。是的。好吧。停火协议已经达成，谈判即将开始，在下一期的《历史余音》中，我们将与爱尔兰谈判代表团一起重返伦敦，讲述那个非凡的故事。其中有一些了不起的人物：大卫·劳合·乔治、温斯顿·丘吉尔、迈克尔·柯林斯，当然，还有隐身于幕后、影响深远的埃蒙·德瓦莱拉。非常深远。剧透一下，他们不会得到他们期望的和平。他们发现自己将踏上一场残酷而血腥的内战。
Exactly. Yeah. All right. So the truth has been agreed, the negotiations will begin and the next time on the rest of history, we will return with the Irish negotiating team to London to tell that extraordinary story. Some amazing characters, David Lloyd George, Winston Churchill, Michael Collins, of course, and off stage the long shadow of Eamon de Valera. Very long. And spoiler alert, they will not get the piece they are hoping for. They will find themselves embarking on a bitter and bloody civil war.
但是，保罗，在这一集结束时，我们应该给你雷鸣般的掌声，因为你一天之内录了三集。是的。这是一项极其宏大的成就。和往常一样，我们对你感激不尽。这就是《历史余音》。我们也感谢克罗克公园的工作人员接待我们。非常感谢你把这一切安排得井井有条。
But Paul, we should give you a massive round of applause at the end of that episode because you've done three episodes in one day. Yeah. A Herculean achievement. We are enormously indebted to you as ever. The rest is history. And we're indebted to the staff here at Crete Park for hosting us. And thank you so much for setting it all up.
是的。非常感谢你们的邀请。这绝对是我的荣幸。非常感谢你，保罗。再见。再见。大家好。你们竟然还在听这一集的结尾。我对你们的执着深表钦佩。
Yeah. Thank you very much for the invitation. It's an absolute pleasure. Thank you so much, Paul. Bye bye. Bye bye. Hi everybody. You're still here right at the end of the episode. I'm very impressed by your commitment.
但是听着，我有个问题想问你们。我想私下问你们一件事。你们有时会听这些节目里的广告吗？你们有时会想：“你知道吗？我希望这个播客的听众听到的不是汤姆和多米尼克在节目里推广的其他东西，而是关于我品牌的广告。”如果你有过这种想法，当然，只有一个方法能知道那会是什么感觉。你可以打断广告的常规播放，你就可以成为下一个汇丰卓越理财（HSBC Premier）或在《历史余音》上做过广告的众多优秀公司之一。你可以将你的品牌展现给数百万志同道合的听众。
But listen, I have a question for you. I want to ask you something in confidence. Do you sometimes listen to the adverts on these episodes? And do you sometimes think, do you know what? I wish that the listeners to this podcast, I wish they were listening to an advert about my brand rather than the other stuff that Tom and Dominic are promoting on here. If you have thought that there is of course, only one way to find out what that would be like. You can disrupt the procession of adverts. You could be the next HSBC Premier or the many other tremendous companies that have advertised on the rest is history. And you could put your brand in front of millions of like-minded
但是听着，我有个问题想问你。我想私下问你一件事。你有时会听这些节目里的广告吗？你有时会想，你知道吗？我希望这个播客的听众，我希望他们听的是关于我品牌的广告，而不是汤姆和多米尼克在这里推广的其他东西。如果你有过这种想法，当然只有一个方法可以知道那会是什么样的。你可以打破广告的流程。你可以成为下一个汇丰卓越理财（HSBC Premier）或曾在《历史之源》（The Rest is History）上做过广告的许多其他伟大公司之一。你可以将你的品牌展现在数百万志同道合的受众面前
listeners by advertising on the rest is history and indeed the other shows on the Goalhanger Network. Now you may be thinking, I don other shows on the Goalhanger Network. Now you may be thinking, I don't know what the Goalhanger Network is. Goalhanger are the company behind this very show. And if you are in the market to increase the value of your brand, Goalhanger would love to hear from you. You can register your interest, or indeed your company's interest, by going to Goalhanger.com right now.
通过在《The Rest is History》以及Goalhanger网络旗下的其他节目上投放广告来吸引听众。你现在可能会想，我不知道Goalhanger网络是什么。Goalhanger正是制作这档节目的公司。如果你正打算提升你的品牌价值，Goalhanger非常希望能听到你的声音。你可以立即登录 Goalhanger.com 登记你或你公司的兴趣。
And that is Goal, G-O-A-L, Hangar, H-A-N-G-E-R, dot com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 Goal，拼写是 G-O-A-L，Hangar，拼写是 H-A-N-G-E-R，点 com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。